You know that feeling when you can't
stop scrolling, but you're not even
enjoying it? That's because what makes
you want something and what makes you
like something are completely different?
We've been confusing the two our whole
lives. Think about it. Planning the
vacation feels more exciting than being
on it. The anticipation of checking
messages feels better than actually
reading them. Here's the problem. By
breakfast, you've had more stimulation
than your grandparents had in a week.
You've been eating candy for breakfast
and now vegetables taste like cardboard.
But here's what sounds crazy but
actually works. The cure for feeling
unmotivated is doing hard things. When
you push through something difficult,
you're not withdrawing from your
motivation account. You're depositing.
And the trick? Effort pays compound
interest. Each hard thing you do makes
the next hard thing easier. You're
training yourself to crave the
challenge.